I saw a weakness in you on your latest
podcast you seem to overlook the fact
that some infant children were raised in
undisciplined environments with
undisciplined parents they grow up
having modeled these undisciplined
examples I hate the fact that I have
gross undisciplined behavior solving
this is a major priority in my life
you have zero idea of what it of what
this experience is like for me
you seem blind to this struggle like a
father who would ignore their child
struggle and offer only the words mana
so this is a good question and I I see
where this guy's coming from for sure
and I know that it can be very very
frustrating to try and become
disciplined and I apologize that I
haven't talked about the fact of what to
do if you come from an undisciplined
family or you have undisciplined parents
I haven't really talked about what to do
in that situation but there's a reason
that I haven't talked about that before
and that is because you don't get
discipline from your parents you don't
get discipline from your parents from
your grandparents from your older
brothers and sisters you don't get
discipline from an external source you
have to get it from you that's what
self-discipline is you get it from
yourself you get it from you so there's
people from every possible background
from no parents to crazy parents to you
no drug-addicted parents to super
squared away parents and everywhere in
between on that spectrum that are
completely disciplined people more
disciplined than anyone I know it
doesn't come from your parents you don't
inherit it and there's another piece
here
it's called ownership right it's called
ownership and if you're if you want to
blame other people for the problem and I
say this all the time if you don't take
ownership of the problem the problems
not gonna get solved so if you blame
your parents for not having raised you
in a disciplined environment you're not
gonna solve that problem you're looking
at your parents saying if you would have
done a better job being more disciplined
for me I would be more discipline now so
that means that means you can't do
anything the fact the matter is it's
wrong you actually can do something and
it doesn't matter what how your parents
raised you and brought you up you can
have the discipline you need to decide
to do it so as long as you're blaming
other people I mean if you blame me from
not discussing it you blame me for
having zero idea what that experience is
like you blame your parents for not
raising you this way as long as you're
blaming other people as long as you're
counting on other people to give you
discipline as long as you do that you
will not have it so again I I'm sorry I
should have made that my I should make
that more clearly I'm trying to make it
more clearly now and like my parents my
parents are good people they had
successful careers as as educators in
public schools and my mom eventually
became went into school administration
and my dad taught in high school for
30-something years and they were good
hard-working people and but I'll tell
you they were no they were no
extraordinary preachers of discipline
and I'll tell you I I in fact I I never
remember either one of them ever using
the term or referring to discipline in
any way you know when actually both my
parents worked they both worked a lot my
dad was coaching sports and we're doing
after school stuff my mom's same thing
like we were on our own a bunch but my
parents were gone in the morning we got
ourselves to school when we got home in
afternoon they weren't home you know so
it wasn't like they were setting up this
rigid disciplined manner for me right
and and you can see this with family
many many different families there's
families that have kids that the parents
are very disciplined and the kids are
wild mm-hm and how to control it
sometimes that problematically so right
kids that come from really good families
but they get addicted to drugs lack of
discipline kids that come from really
good families but they they spin out of
control and go in the wrong direction
and there's also the opposite which is
hey the parents weren't around or the
parents were abusive or the parents were
drug addicts and and all the cousins the
kid the kid comes out of that and is
squared away is awesome and we saw that
all the time the SEAL Teams and I've
said that before on this program doesn't
matter it doesn't matter where your
background is is what you decide to do
yeah
[Music]
and I'll tell you another thing it's not
even from the military like the military
requires discipline obviously but
there's plenty of people in the military
that don't have it right and and many
poor many people lose their discipline
when they leave the mulch because not
being imposed on them anymore so I mean
just go look around I mean being in the
military does not make you a disciplined
person being from a discipline family
does not make you a discipline person
being in a discipline group does not
make you a discipline person what makes
you a discipline person is choosing to
be disciplined so yeah I I and also as
far as telling people to man up which
you know when someone says how do I get
up early every day I say get up early
every day how do I stop eating sugar
stop eating sugar look that's the
definition of mana but obvious it's not
just men that need discipline in their
life I don't think I used that term but
what I do tell people is to get after it
that's what I tell people to get after
it you know I tell people to do the
things that they know they're supposed
to do right there's things that you know
you're supposed to do as a human being
things that you know are going to
improve your life do those things
there's things that you know are gonna
make you a worse person and make your
life worse don't do those things don't
do the things that are making you weaker
start
during four things that are gonna make
you stronger and smarter and faster and
healthier and gonna make you a better
human being and I'll say the same thing
to this guy you want to be more
disciplined get after it that's it get
up early do some kind of work out eat
good foods clean your room make a list
of things that you're supposed to do in
your life and then wake up in the
morning and do those things that you put
on the list
that's what discipline is and no it is
not easy but you're not gonna get it
from anyone else but you and it's worth
it and it is the thing that is going to
bring you freedom that's the key word
right there when he said it's worth it
you know what I think this is what I
think I think like in an environment as
like how he put it an undisciplined
environment right or something like that
where he grew up in an undisciplined
environment mm-hmm I don't obviously
that's a very vague expression really
undisciplined infirm yeah that meaning
that could mean a lot of yeah a lot of
different things so a lot of times like
when you're brought up in a certain
environment basically you're kind of
taught or or not taught like like the
value of certain things so if you use
like I don't know working out or
whatever right so I'm gonna use myself
as an example my dad was an athlete you
know not this superior athlete but he
was you know he knew like working out
was a part of life and stuff like that
and you know in elementary school we're
doing sports and stuff like that you
know some people they don't do that at
all so and when they grow up into
adulthood that some people straight up
have never worked out before never been
in the gym and you know so growing up
they they were never taught the value of
what work you know does for you they
never taught so they can't appreciate it
they just simply don't know the value
sure they see people with you know you
know they're in shape where they can do
these things and they're very functional
whatever they see that of course but
they don't have that value they don't
feel that value they just never learned
it so it can come off as like
thing for other people you know I
thought that's what other people do kind
of thing so they don't understand the
value so back to the point in their mind
this weird the connection is not made
that it's worth it because they don't
know the value of it really but if you
do know the value of it and then you can
decide okay is this worth it is it worth
it to wake up every day and in
quote-unquote get after it
for this particular goal or this
particular set of goals so that's what
it is and I think sure the undisciplined
environment can maybe provide that but I
think you're right I think that once
you're like oh yeah that's worth it yeah
you know how people they'll find reasons
when it's worth the even though they've
never experienced like you know like a
person who has a heart attack or
something is like and they have kids
young kids and they have a heart attack
like maybe never worked out ever in
their life they have a heart attack they
almost died they're like guess what I'm
working out every single day I'm a
vegetarian now you know like doing major
major changes that they've never even
thought about making and they'll do it
because they decided it's worth it and
they'll be disciplined they'll find that
discipline real quick no matter how
they're trained as you know their
environment because now I see that it's
gonna be worth it that's it yeah and if
it's not worth it to you and that I
think is what you develop the value of
work you know the value of you develop
you can develop that from anywhere
that's one of that's but essentially
that has really developed that from any
any you can develop that from from
anyway yeah yeah you can get it from
parents you can get from yeah exactly
right exactly right but the discipline
itself just like I said that's gonna
come from you your parents can teach it
but guess who has to it's still you it's
still you and you can go to the military
to specifically learn discipline when
you leave it's on you who's it yeah
exactly right and just like I said like
yeah I know people who are done with the
military and are glad they're done with
that right they're glad with this waking
up early the other big one were six
months they're out of shape they're not
doing anything productive it's it's
horrible to see you know but it happens
happens with the military it happens
with anything yeah when kids get out of
high school sports you know and all the
sudden they don't want enough to do that
don't listen to coach yeah yeah crazy -
don't listen to coach listen to yourself
yourself yeah determine whether or not
it's worth it and I'm telling you that
you don't need to determine I'm telling
you it's worth it oh yeah I'm telling
you it's worth it and you know what you
actually know it's worth it that's why
you're asking this question you know
it's worth that you know it's worth it
to have discipline but you think there's
an easier way you think that it's
something that people have you think
that when Jacko's alarm clock goes off
it's like oh just like my father taught
me
I rise and I shine you know like no I
it's like the pillow feels soft and
comfortable and the alarm clock is
banging on my head and I don't like it
you know what I know it's worth it to
get up and get after it I know it's
worth it and you know it's worth it
here's the thing we all know it's worth
it here's it in a way you're right but
like really though really I'm gonna be
open open and honest with you I don't
think that the people know it's worth it
I think they know it's worth it like the
kind on paper they have a multiple
choice question
is it worth it yes or no they'll be like
yes obviously I know working out is
worth it but here's the thing I don't if
you don't know if you don't like like
having good credit
for example so I never got taught like
why really my mom said yeah you should
have good credit that's it that's the
limit to my education on credit right so
of course I blow it because I get you
know I fall for literally all the tricks
it's self-inflicted and otherwise credit
gets jammed up so I don't know I don't
know the value I don't know I've never
experienced the benefits of having good
credit so really did it mean much to me
really my credit was like junk and I
didn't care until I got denied for
something then I cared you know but just
like if you're never into working out
until you're in a specific situation
we're not sure but but but like this guy
that's asking this question and glad
he's asking the question I'm I'm not I'm
trying I'm not trying to come off all
hard but he realizes he realizes the
value of discipline cuz he's saying that
he wants it right he knows that it's
gonna make his life better yeah and and
that's why I think he's got
and jammed up in whatever way we don't
know cuz I don't know maybe he's gotten
unhealthy maybe he's you know who knows
maybe he's gotten his finances jammed up
whatever the case may be
he knows that discipline is better for
them him he knows that he does know this
isn't a guy that doesn't know yet cuz
sure there's people that don't you know
when you're 16 years old you don't know
the value of discipline you don't know
that the what your the way you're acting
right now is gonna affect you in five
years you don't know that you can set
yourself your whole life up to be pretty
awesome
you know you don't know that yet you're
just like worried about where you're
going on a Friday night right yeah so
this guy knows and he wants it and he's
looking for where he can find it and
where he can find it is in the mirror
yeah that's where it is you know so do
it brother good luck get on the path and
stay on the path yeah and that's gonna
be beneficial one you do that harshly
maintaining that like not knowing them
value is a big is a big thing it's kind
of like okay so back to my credit thing
I there is a point at the end where okay
so you know like I don't know ten years
ago or whatever I repaired my credit my
credit was repaired I thought I went
through it was painstaking not fun stuff
no but I did it got my credit repaired
and now I know the value because as an
adult I'm functioning it's useful now
you know so now I know the value of
having good credit because I've been
through all the things that having good
credit
brings you through you know now I'm
thinking I'll never go back to
background right never it's worth it
every single day
I'm telling you that I agree with what
you're saying yeah I agree with what
you're saying I'm saying that this guy
knows the value that's why he wants it
yeah it's like when you free realize
that you got denied for something and
you're like oh wow oh credit has value I
understand that something happened in
his life where he said discipline has
value I know that now but you did credit
repair and in what you said was okay I
need to go out and repair my credit you
didn't say hey you know what my mom
didn't tell me about bad credit now I
have bad credit yeah yeah so now so now
what am I supposed to do you know who
repaired your credit who repaired your
credit well it was a combination of my
wife and I but
but who repaired your credit yeah we yes
yeah you took responsibility for and
said okay I'm gonna get my credit or
your wife cuz she's smarter than you yes
she was like hey I will I will help this
but it was you that said okay I got to
get this fixed mm-hmm and you got help
but you knew to reach out for help but
you're the one that ultimately is
responsible for it
yeah you're right about that like I
didn't like I didn't blame my parents
and then continue having that good right
you know right like they said no I gotta
get Val this is this thing has credit
has value I need to fix it yeah and you
fixed it you know regardless where it
came from
regardless so oh you know oh you don't
know how to work out cool then you go
hire a personal trainer because you know
it's gonna it's the right thing to do
you don't even know you don't know how
to repair your finances cool go get a
counselor that's gonna help you repair
your finances oh you're addicted to
drugs or alcohol okay I'm gonna go find
a counselor or join a group so I can get
through that thing yeah no one's gonna
hold your hand and bring you into the
any of those situations you got to do it
yourself you gather the discipline to
make it happen